MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to "DataVis DevTalk."
I'm your host, Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
In this episode of date
of "DataVis DevTalk,"
you will learn about
different approaches
to build custom solutions
with BigQuery and Data Studio.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BigQuery is Google's
fully-managed petabytes scale
low cost data
warehousing solution.
Data Studio natively
integrates with BigQuery,
and can be used to analyze
and visualize BigQuery data.
You can also use a new BigQuery
BI engine with Data Studio
to build rich interactive
dashboards and reports
without compromising
performance, scale, security
or data freshness.
When you're trying to
build a reporting solution
from your BigQuery data,
there are several approaches
you can take.
In this video, we'll talk about
the recommended approaches
for different use cases.
You can use the native BigQuery
connector in Data Studio
to fetch and visualize
BigQuery create data.
You can fetch entire
cables from BigQuery
or run custom queries
within Data Studio.
This approach is
useful if your users
are doing exploratory analysis
and are familiar with SQL
and can write their own queries,
and are familiar with the data
and know how to visualize
it from scratch.
When using the native BigQuery
connector, you or your users
can also take advantage
of the Explorer feature
indeed Data Studio to
visually construct the queries
without writing custom SQL.
Keep in mind, that your users
will need a BigQuery billing
account to use the
native BigQuery
connector in Data Studio UI.
There are other use cases
when you might need a more
customized solution.
One use case is where you want
to incorporate existing queries
into your connector.
Your users won't have
to write their own SQL
or copy paste SQL snippets
to get the exact query.
Additionally, you can
parameterize your queries
and let your users provide input
via the connector configuration
to customize the queries.
Another use case
is when you want
to use service accounts
to centralize billing.
This means your users
will not need access
to a GCB billing account to
query and visualize their data.
Other use cases include
getting your users started
with template reports
populated with their own data,
and implementing your
own cache in there
to control BigQuery cost.
In all these cases, it is useful
to create a custom solution
with a community connector.
In a community connector,
you can access BigQuery
in three separate ways--
Data Studio Advanced
Services, BigQuery REST API,
and Apps Script
BigQuery Service.
Most of the custom use cases
can be solved with Data Studio
Advanced Services.
While using the service
in your connector,
you provide a query
configuration in the code.
Based on this
configuration, Data Studio
will fetch the data for you
using its native connection
to BigQuery.
This works as fast as the
native BigQuery connector,
since the data does not
pass through Apps Script
and does not require any
additional transformation.
Any filters added
to the dashboard
are automatically
pushed down to BigQuery,
so the connector
does not get bogged
down with handling excess data.
This approach requires
the least amount
of code among the
three separate ways,
since you're passing only
configuration to Data Studio.
The World Bank example connector
in our open source repo
uses Data Studio
Advanced Services.
Link is in the description,
if you want to see the code.
We will have a
separate video showing
how you can use the Data
Studio Advanced Services when
building your own connector.
When you use the Data
Studio Advanced Services,
the connector code
does not get access
to the data being
fetched from BigQuery,
so it is not possible to
implement your own caching
there.
You also cannot do additional
transformations or calculations
with the data.
In these cases, you
can use the App Script
URL fetch app service to
access the BigQuery REST API.
This approach lets you send off
your query to the BigQuery REST
endpoint and get back your
query results in your connector.
You can then implement
custom caching
or do additional
transformation, as required.
For an example of BigQuery
REST API implementation,
check out the
[INAUDIBLE] connector.
Link is in the description.
Apps Script BigQuery
Service is useful
when you need to do manual
calculation or cross
formation in your connector, but
are hitting the URL fetch app
limits due to large data sizes.
This approach does
have its limitations,
since you cannot use the service
account to access BigQuery this
way.
To quickly summarize, use
the native BigQuery connector
to create dashboards when your
users are exploring the data
and are familiar with
the data set and SQL.
For custom solutions,
create community connectors
to access BigQuery.
Data Studio Advanced
Services should
address most of the issues,
unless you need access
to the data in your code.
In such cases, use the BigQuery
REST API or the Apps Script
BigQuery Service.
All of these approaches
support calculated fields
in the schema, and can
use templated reports
with the connector.
To learn more, check out the
links in the description below.
And don't forget to
subscribe to the GCB channel
for more great content
on Data Studio.
Thanks for watching,
and until next time,
keep building
awesome dashboards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]